we basically knew that this would happen
step one was the faux vindication of
Donald Trump claiming to be totally
exonerated when Robert molars report
literally says it cannot exonerate
Donald Trump from obstruction of justice
and we've already talked about all the
other problems contained in the bar
report which I've now explained I think
enough times some on the Monday show
someone that's used they show some of
the ones they show that I'm not going to
go through it all in detail again today
but part of that framing of total and
unmitigated exoneration from Donald
Trump was that he was the victim of
something here
despite 37 indictments despite the
report saying that Moeller cannot
exonerate Donald Trump from obstruction
the framing that Donald Trump and the
people around him have adopted over the
last few days has been that the
investigation represents an unfair
politically partisan attack on the
President of the United States that was
phase one okay now they're moving on to
Phase two and we knew that phase two
would happen which is to start to accuse
those who investigated him individually
of wrongdoing and in particular Donald
Trump is now accusing some particular
FBI officials who investigated him of
treason which is a ridiculous standard
to try to apply to what they did in
carrying out their jobs for the federal
government but we'll get to that in a
second Donald Trump gave an interview to
Fox News to Sean Hannity of course this
was his first interview I think since
the Moller report was handed over to
William Barr on Friday and ultimately we
got the bar report the summary of a
summary on Sunday and in this interview
with Sean Hannity Donald Trump says that
individual FBI employees Peter struck
and Lisa page committed treason this is
the word that Donald Trump is using
treason
merely by participating in a legal FBI
investigation which is ridiculous is
kind of the only way I can say it take a
look at this clip from the interview
last night it was many months before
that that straat can page we're talking
about the insurance policy right an
insurance policy just in case
Hilary Clinton lost they wanted an
insurance policy against me and what we
were playing out until just recently was
the insurance policy they wanted to do a
subversion it was treason it was really
treason if the Republican Party had done
this to the Democrats if we had done
this to President Obama you'd have a
hundred people in jail right now and it
would be treason it would be considered
treason and they'd be in jail for the
rest of their lives
funny that he mentions if this was Obama
right
imagine if what we have seen between
Trump and Russia we had seen between
Obama and Iran that's actually the Obama
comparison that seems most relevant to
me which I actually saw a James Comey
bring up in an interview yesterday I
believe it was and it can be really easy
to lose sight of the facts when Trump is
kind of hurling these generalized
allegations in this way you have to
break it down into individual sort of
practical answerable questions was the
investigation illegal of course it
wasn't the answer is no was the
investigation started on some kind of
partisan pretense or with no probable
cause no and in fact the more we learn
about the more we realize all of the
probable cause that sort of served as a
catalyst for this investigation to get
going from the beginning so then we get
to did individuals break the law by
being employed by the FBI and doing the
work that they were told to do in terms
of this investigation of course they
didn't and then we get to the
allegations specifically of treason
which is the crime of betraying one's
country by especially by attempting to
kill the sovereign or to overthrow the
government that's not what an FBI
employee participating in a legal
investigation is guilty of obviously
that is not treason and when Donald
Trump just throws out the nonsense in
this way in unfortunately kind of works
and I hope that most people and I know
that I'm kind of preaching to the choir
here in our audience I think people
understand working for the FBI and doing
what you're
sign to do is not treason but I know for
sure that I will start getting
voicemails and tweets and emails from
Trump is saying it was treason David
what the FBI investigators did was
treason because it was part of an
attempt to overthrow the administration
of the president Donald Trump and that's
why this is unfortunately effective when
Donald Trump goes on Fox News and he
comes up with this stuff the FBI agents
who were doing the investigation or
treasonous it filters down there is
actually a sort of trickle-down effect
and I don't know you know in five or ten
years how is this entire fiasco going to
be remembered I don't know the answer to
that but I do believe that it's
important not to forget forget that we
had the Trump Tower Moscow deal we had
Trump firing the FBI director and
admitting it was to stop the probe Trump
calling for Russians to hack Hillary's
emails which they did or maybe had
already done and Trump knew it at that
point in time
Trump associates meeting with Russians
in Trump Tower we all know what we saw
we also knew that Trump personally
colluding was not going to be the
outcome certainly not at least rising to
criminality we were all saying that for
more than a year at this point in time
so the result of the probe that is no
collusion charges against Trump really
does come away it was predictable and it
was common sense from the beginning but
my concern here is the total
whitewashing of the bigger picture
because the investigations continue
Muller did indict 37 people I believe it
is we need to get a full copy of the
report and when we allow things to sort
of slide in the direction of crazy and I
would say the individuals doing the
investigation being treasonous falls
under the umbrella of crazy it makes it
really difficult to actually communicate
the truth of what took place and is
still taking place and this is why I
said at the top of the show I was
thinking yesterday is it even worth
bothering like is it even worth
researching and putting together stories
about
why the bar letter is a joke and why the
legalese is pointing to deception
because once again I think a lot of our
audience gets it and the people that
don't are committed I don't know if 100
percent committed but 99.9% committed to
whatever framing they are accepting from
either Trump or from elements on the
left that they find appealing maybe it's
not worth it and I just shouldn't talk
about it anymore I don't know let me
know what you think does it make sense
to continue to try to break this stuff
down you can clean up your remote
control clutter with today's sponsor
control center by kaavo which simplifies
your home theater so you can control
everything connected to your TV with one
easy-to-use remote that has voice
control you can plug in your streamer
your sound system cable or satellite
your game console and the control center
will do it all stop fiddling with
different remotes or what I do often
breaking multiple remotes as I try to
figure out which is the right one no
weeding through messy search results to
get the content you want one universal
voice remote controls at all say what
you want to watch control center handles
the rest
take your at-home entertainment
experience from stressful to simple
enjoy what you want when you want it
I've set it up with my TV sound system
and DVD player it has made everything
much much simpler you can shop now and
get 40% off of control center with promo
code Pakman that's 59.95 40% off regular
pricing of 99.95 service plan required
first 45 days are free control center is
available at CAA vo comm and best buy
the control center by kaavo one remote
that does it all